let me ask you this like um would there
ever be a point in time
not to be in the griselda business but
were you like obviously it's always
griselda but will you like leave the
label
as far as like contractually or do you
kind of feel like you'll always kind of
be
done now
so any music moving forward
is gonna be drum work
yeah
yeah drum work i mean
as of right now yeah
like sitting right here right now like
my i'm not on a contract with
zelda shady none of that [ __ ] no more
i mean [ __ ] this is this the first time
in your career that is free agency right
now you heard with that being said we
all and we all and we also need that i
need that supermax man i need they they
giannis the giannis bag
yeah and even if that doesn't happen
it's still you know grizzled is still
family gun is still family of course
that's mine that's for life i'm saying
man man being broke you know what i'm
saying i put that [ __ ] on my back man
wes took that we we've been no i mean
the the analogy you had about
doing the construction and all that is
very uh yeah yeah that's some real [ __ ]
um
are you guys trying to
you know do the you know do the
extension or you just kind of we haven't
really talked about that who knows like
i'm sure
you know i mean that's
yeah all of our intentions yeah i'm
saying in the perfect world
right like you know what i'm saying
but i'm just saying that's right now
like it's the end like you know the
paperwork i signed was
it's been fulfilled it's been fulfilled
as well as with it was all in together
like my shady paperwork and gazelle the
paperwork
everything's been fulfilled feathering
has been fulfilled and now
it's time to sit back at the round table
and figure out the future
what it got in store for me and you know
or just get or you know gazi will just
give you that that drum work situation
at empire and then yes
and now you are
you got your own yeah man
you can't just take the flight to san
francisco figure it out with ghazi and
nema and hey man oh guys you're gonna
take good care of you i wanna think
about olga a hundred percent a hundred
percent